how do you think about the balance
between be yourself versus choose
yourself
uh elaborate consider them so so we've
talked a lot about how
you're
you know you went on this journey trying
to uncover your true self
um
one school of thought is that well we
don't really have a true self that true
self is just a result of the accidents
of our um the accidents of the way that
we were brought up and it just and the
traits we got from our parents and from
our friends at school
and
you can
do a lot to change who you are if that's
what you want want to do for example
when i was in school i wasn't
particularly outgoing or particularly
charismatic or particularly confident
and i recognized that
you know
me being myself would have been me just
continuing on that route i decided you
know what i'm going to make an active
decision at university to change myself
to become someone who's more confident
and more charismatic
where and someone who is a little bit
more outgoing and although that was not
a natural transformation initially it
felt it felt uncomfortable like any
change which always feels it feels
uncomfortable i am now much more
confident charismatic open in social
settings that kind of stuff
but if i'd been told um oh bro just be
yourself it would have probably that
probably wouldn't have happened and so
i'm curious as to what what your
thoughts are on that so
i believe that your life should be lived
by design not by default
that you should be intentionally doing
things because the default quite often
is actually a bit [ __ ]
the default setting that you would go to
would be the netflix and
bag of chips and
not doing hard things and not having new
experiences and all of the biases or you
would just be ruled by your biases right
which is definitely not what you want
that being said we are not infinitely
malleable we are not complete blank
slates there are predispositions that
you have that i do not and there are
predispositions i have that you do not
50 pretty much of everything you are
psychologically is genetic
on average
[Laughter]
and what that means is that you are
inclined towards certain things more
than others
by hooker by crook you haven't ended up
being an artist
or a
painter or a
club promoter or a reality tv guy yeah
like there is something inside of you
that has caused you to lean toward the
particular life that you do
now
understanding yourself and saying right
i'm going to
play to my strengths i'm going to
enhance so one of your strengths is
being able to learn things quickly right
so
you have a meta power that permits you
to be more malleable than most people
but it's not unlimited
you can't learn to be anything that you
want you can just learn to be
you can manipulate certain areas of you
to enhance some and to down regulate
others
the difference between
be yourself and choose yourself is
interesting
but especially as you grow up
your
life paths they do start to get closed
off more right because you have less and
less time presumably most people will
want to start a family of some kind
which again is something that you're
working toward as you grow up and
yeah it's an interesting one i think um
i think that choosing yourself has
a beauty to it and a sense of
achievement once you've completed it
i think that's really really nice and
you can feel proud of the person that
you are
but that needs to come from a place of
inner truth or else you're just going to
end up playing a role you're not going
to be so if you decided tomorrow that
you wanted to wake up and be a pt in a
gym and just be some super alpha go out
sniff a bag with the boys on a weekend
like five pints and watch the footy or
did you see the west ham game last night
mate like if you decided to be that guy
i'm sure that you could probably you
absolutely could force yourself into it
if someone held a gun to your head and
said right you got to be the biggest lad
that you can for the next year you could
do it but it wouldn't be
you
so you can't fully choose yourself you
could
act
yourself
but the difference between chews and
bees basically does this feel like it's
cohesive with my inner desire and what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
remove the distance from what you would
do and what you want to do so what would
i do if i woke up this morning i would
maybe
do some meditation and do some walking
it's can i get something from system two
to system one and the more that you get
the things that you want in system two
to system one that's you creating
yourself to be yourself does that make
sense
like if you can choose the things that
you want to have in life and you can
make them so much a part of you that
they actually end up embodying you and
you embody them that feels like that
feels like you've managed to merge the
two together yeah it's sort of like
habit formation but for personality
traits i guess yeah and also for the
values that you have yeah for me i was a
guy that took a lot of pride from the
success of his club night and from the
way that he was seen and blah blah blah
don't get me wrong i've probably just
transmuted them into other different
like desires and wants and
[ __ ] um but i got rid of those ones
because i didn't want them anymore so i
guess you can choose yourself but you're
not infinitely malleable